In the previous videos, you could see us doing many projects.
Setting up Basekamp with containers, decks and roofs.
Renovating a ruin, or transforming the landscape.
But, we rarely talk about other stuff at the Kamp,
that is essential for our project.
In this video, we will show them to you.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update.
So, the Project Kamp you have normally seen in
the videos, has a lot to do with building...
Renovating...
Digging...
And, chopping...
But, there is a lot of things
that happens behind the scenes.
And, many of you asked in the comments
what happens beyond the projects we do.
And, in this video, we will show you.
Come with me!
So, the first thing you need to know
is that we are organize in seasons.
From April to November, we work on projects,
During the winter, we reflect and plan,
on what will come next season.
We have people staying long term,
and managing the project over the different seasons.
And then, we have short term people coming to help,
with their skills for a part or for the whole season.
But, as we grow, we need systems to organize.
One of the important ones is the weekly planning board.
This is our weekly plan board!
Every monday morning, we meet here with the whole group,
and we organize our week.
We mark events here that will happen during the day.
People that will be coming, people that will be going...
We also have the teams that clean
throughout the week on each specific day.
And then, we also use this time
to try to learn a bit of Portuguese every week.
We have a team that prepares the bread.
And, a team responsible
to prepare the pizza night, on Friday night.
And then, the development work in the Kamp
is organized around different teams
Like, the workspace, which renovates,
builds and creates awesome stuff!
Or, general help that clears out invasive species, plants native trees,
or just discovers waterfalls and lagoons.
So, these are the teams that you normally see,
when the projects are being made.
But, in order for these projects
to be uploaded on YouTube, we need a--
At the moment, there are two people making the videos:
Javier and Gui.
And, also, Dave is always around helping.
Now, I realize you don't know much about Gui,
so maybe it's a good moment to introduce him.
Hi, my name is Guilherme!
I'm 20 years old, and I am from Portugal.
Here, I am a video editor.
But, I am also passionate about nature, music, coding,
bikes, hand work, meeting people, and apparently fixing stuff that I break...
I came to Project Kamp,
because I wanted to work so much with Javier.
because I was really inspired by it.
And, I believe that the project
is doing something good for the planet.
I don't have a concrete thing that I want to do in the future...
But, for sure, I want to do something,
that makes the world around me a little bit better...
Just like this video!
So, keep watching it!
Now that you know the video making team,
they can explain as our Project Kamp videos are created.
Question number one: how do we do the videos?
Last season, we set a system where people will actually
record themselves, like the team that are doing the projects.
Then, they download all the clips
in a computer we have over there.
So, here's an old MacBook
with a broken screen.
We took it off and now we have a screen.
So, we have this funky, weird laptop...
Well, it's not a laptop, but a PC...
I don't know...
This thing.
With that footage, we will go in and start editing the video.
We brought all the files, put it in a timeline, start chopping...
- The chopping!
♩ And I love chopping ♩
And then, yeah, we figured out what's missing.
The script, some voiceovers and intros,
record what's needed,
And then, put of all the pieces together with some nice music,
and some background noises.
And, that's pretty much it.
- Sounds easy!
It's not.
We have three Sony ZV-1's, six GoPro's...
- So, one GoPro flashed away.
Now, it's somewhere there.
But, there are a lot of brambles...
We like to buy secondhand,
and these ones are cheaper and still good quality.
- If you have anything to replace, or just for
the sake of teaching the people how to use the cameras...
It's better if it's just the same model.
- We also have a drone: a MoVI Pro, that I just broke.
And then, repaired, so that's good...
For music, we use SoundStripe.
It's a paid platform
where you can get music
- Is that where you found the banjo music?
And, this funky music.
- I like funky music.
I like it, but...
People prefer folk sometimes
It's hard to be good to everyone.
- It's hard for him not to copy my music.
Yeah...
We use DaVinci Resolve for editing.
We used to use Premiere, but it's paid to compatibility issues.
So, we stick with DaVinci.
Its free! It's good! It does the job!
- Sorry Adobe.
I think they can manage...
- And, how are the flies?
They're everywhere!
Sticking to my sweating skin.
I also have a question for you, Dave!
- What's that?
Can I get the camera?
Okay!
So Dave, how about the results of the channel and the videos?
It's cool!
I think the main challenge for us is always to integrate it properly.
The people in the film know how to do it,
and then deliver good files to the editor.
So, the system feels pretty good.
And also, the channel, I mean,
everyone leaves good comments!
Channel is growing, so it's cool.
Yeah, this year, we started really going more
for integrating Patreons, which has been really cool.
Also, to not depend too much on Google,
to pay the bills but more direct from people.
Which, yeah, it's been growing a lot,
so that's really cool!
Feels like the long term thing,
that's going to fuel up Project Kamp.
So, one thing we're gonna try...
I know, it's a sensitive point.
It's to integrate an advertisement.
Mainly because it will give us quite an extra amount of money,
to just build buildings and stuff.
And we already have this anyway from YouTube,
but we also don't want to compromise the video.
So, we're trying to find this balance,
and selecting things that we actually think make sense.
So, being very critical in the product...
And also, finding a way to integrate it
nicely in the video.
So, we're going to give that a try!
We're not sure if we're going to keep it.
So, if y'all don't like it, we will stop it.
But, we want to at least give it a try...
So, we get real YouTubers!
With that, we're going to make it that the Patreons
don't see any advertisements, if you support on Patreon.
And, we also are going to start
uploading in 4K.
So, even more reasons to become a Patreon!
We're trying to find this balance,
between how to sustain a project, and get enough income...
But, yeah, do it in a way that you think makes sense.
So, we're exploring sturdy options,
whether it's Patreon, YouTube and other kind of funding.
Like, we don't know yet,
so we're still figuring it out...
So, money comes in, but where does it go?
Well, a big part goes into developing the projects itself.
For instance:  buying materials, tools, containers, a trailer...
But, then, in order to have a lot of people in the Kamp
to make this projects happen, we need to take care of them.
So, being with 20 people here, it's around €5 per person per day.
That means €3,000 on supplying people's needs at the Kamp.
And, out of that, the biggest part goes into food,
for which our kitchen team is responsible.
Meet Timo and Paule!
So, we're two people that are working in the kitchen.
And, we're cooking two meals per day, during the week.
It's important to the people to receive their meals on time.
So, we try to be finished at 1 PM with lunch,
and 7 PM with a dinner.
And, also, it helps to have two people in the kitchen, I guess!
Because, when one is feeling more hectic,
you can kind of balance it out a bit.
It's nice to have a little bit more time, to divide the tasks.
And yeah, don't be stressed in the kitchen at all!
We have a super big fridge,
that is sometimes very full, and a bit chaotic...
But, it helps us store a lot of food!
We have a lot of variety in the meals
we've prepared, in terms of veggies.
To me, the kitchen when I came here
already offered a lot of different spices I could use.
I like the pans we're cooking with!
It's a lot of fun, a lot of creativity needed,
and I really like it to have a fun.
Especially, cooking for 20 people!
Sometimes, it's hard and a challenge
to do for the right amount.
Also, what I really like is to really reuse the leftovers,
and making new stuff out of it.
Or, just putting it in the salad, or stuff like this.
That's one of the things that makes the cooking
most interesting to me here!
Because, we have a set of veggies, that are available to us
And, we find ways of creating interesting meals with them,
that are also like balance in terms of the diets.
For me, it's not a lot of planning at all.
You can improvise, and you can plan, of course...
We have a board to plan the whole week actually,
but I have never used it...
Besides what Paule said about planning,
which is more like the 'day-to-day-prepare-every-meal' stuff...
We do have to take care of having enough supplies here.
We go shopping twice a week to four different places.
There's a small farm run by Nuno,
who grows into regenerative farming.
There's a bigger farm growing in an organic way.
The other two suppliers are in two shops.
One is a bio-shop run by a Dutch couple.
But, we're trying to move more towards a small bulk shop,
where we get most of our bulk supplies nowadays.
We basically try to document everything that we buy and consume,
Knowing our baseline consumption, is it organic?
Is it grown in a regenerative way?
We find out which are the goods, that have the most impact.
Maybe on climate, or social stuff that we can then
switch for other goods.
To have a better, or a less of an impact on the environment.
As they said, we source our food
from outside the Kamp,
But, the bread, that is something we prefer to bake on our own,
Since, we have a nice clay oven,
and a lot of mimosas for fuel.
Right now, I'm at the last stage of the bread making.
The way we make bread.
I'm oiling the molds, and I'm also going to knead the bread
for the last time and cut it in pieces.
We started by one, but right now we are more people,
so we are baking twice a week.
Six breads times two, so twelve breads a week.
Which, in total is like 13 or 14 kilos of bread!
Right now, we are doing 50/50.
50% of the white flour, and 50% whole grain.
We have a bread team, and we are with four people.
Two of them are more into it.
Some of them are starting to learn
how to bake and how to make bread.
I started learning from Adrian and from Javier.
Yeah, I just got into it.
I liked it!
By the week, it was getting better and better.
So, we started trying new things and different ways
of making the dough and baking.
I think, right now, we have pretty good bread,
and I'm happy with it!
Also, because I like the way people react,
to new bread every week and that it's getting better.
I would say the most tricky part is the oven temperature,
and how to bake it, or the time you bake it.
So, if you want to learn,
you can take the research module!
Apart from the video making andfood,
we have a very important area behind the scenes.
A big difference with other off grid projects
is that we document much of the work we do.
We share it online and open source.
This is part of our mission, and the first step for that,
is having a proper documentation to share.
So, the documenting is about getting
all the technical information.
From all the projects, the materials, the cost of the materials,
the tools we've used for building the project...
And also, it's putting the measurements
in 3D-models and 2D-drawings.
So, it's easy for people to replicate it.
Like, to replicate the whole project,
or just replicate that little part of it.
Right now, we are documenting the toilet.
We will be able to upload it in some weeks.
And, here you can see the door! A nice door!
We've already done the tent,
and we've already documented the roof from the container.
We have seen ourselves like ready to start with it!
So, that we can little by little upload all the projects we have.
We can fulfill the vision of the project
Basically, it's giving all this information we have,
in an open source.
Okay, at this point, maybe it's worth to explain some stuff first.
Project Kamp belongs to a bigger family, called One Army.
Which developed other projects, like Precious Plastic,
that shares tools and machines to recycle plastic.
To create a community of plastic recyclers around the world.
Or, Fixing Fashion, that want people to help
to repair and upgrade their clothes.
So, there is less textile waste.
All these projects work on big global problems and are open source,
which means everyone can join.
Have a look on onearmy.earth to see them!
Anyway, for this wealso started to develop
our own software to build communities.
So, people can share knowledge, and collaborate with each other.
We call this software Community Platform.
Sean and Dave can tell us more about it.
So, the community platform underpins
all of the One Army projects.
So, Fixing Fashion, Precious Plastic, Project Kamp...
There's different modules in that.
How-to's, research, the map, events,
and different projects using different modules.
There's lots of contributors and there's a handful of maintainers
Most of them are spread across the world,
and work remotely when they can.
I'm sort trying out working here on the site of Project Kamp,
which is going well, I think.
I'm enjoying it anyway!
- We used to have forums and stuff,
which is a way for peopleto talk with each other on the internet.
But, it became a bit messy, because some people start talking
a lot into a sort of a quick conversation...
And then, you have the good knowledge,
which was hidden and you couldn't find that...
Some features were missing,
like a map to show the entire community.
So, we started developing our own community software.
Basically, it's software to build these communities,
because we believe they should exist more around the world.
And, yeah, this way we can decide for ourselves,
of what features it should have.
And, also reward for instance,
users that make very good long term information.
So you can put the incentives at the right place,
which is currently not necessarily the case in other platforms.
Yeah, so, it's one of those small little things
Instead of liking popular content, we have a useful-button
sp you say this thing is useful!
And, there's a lot of aim for that,
like trying to make useful things.
So, one of the things we've noticed is that
it's quite complex to build software.
Many little hooks and things and interactions,
and so it's quite a big ambitious project.
Even though it's all online,
it's a big piece of infrastructure.
So, the cool thing is it's all online,
and the code is there.
Open source, you could get replicated,
use it, or help out to improve it.
So, if you're a coder and you want to help out,
then I would say go to our GitHub or Discord!
And, you can help building the software!
- Link in the description!
Yeah! Yes!
By now, you know how our week goes,
but Friday's a bit different.
Because, it's the time we take care
to maintain and to clean Basekamp.
We do it all together in the afternoon,
so we don't get distracted during the week.
And, the tasks seems much easier
when we do it collectively.
We clean the kitchen, the workspace,
the toilet and the shower.
We also repair stuff,
do some brush cutting and weeding.
Once that's is done, then we have what we call human hour.
This is a time when we take care of ourselves as a group.
And, we share how we are doing, how we feel,
and give some feedback to each other.
It's kind of a special moment,
which help us to build a sense of community.
After all of this, we can start the weekend together,
and we come together.
We light up the oven and we normally eat pizza.
Although we are trying to introduce
other dishes for some more variety.
And, that's all for now!
I will leave you for this week.
In the next update, we will make a storage
at the outside of our new container.
If you like what we do, you can support us on Patreon.
You will get to watch our next video now, without any ads.
If not, you can subscribe
and help us with the algorithm.
Thanks for watching, and see you in the next week!